I don't think we can create an
organization where everyone every day is
motivated and enthusiastic um that's
like we love our children every day but
we don't like our children every day you
know it's like we can love our work
every day we don't have to like it every
day um we can be inspired work every day
we don't have to be motivated at work
every day you know there are other
things that are factors in our lives and
so I think the most important thing is
that it is a team because no team is
operating with every player at the
highest level every moment of every day
it sort of goes like this you it's like
any kind of relationship um where we
when if if one person is is struggling
for whatever reason that the other
players can come in to to hold them up
and and and help compensate for any work
that needs to get done and and it and
you lean on each other and that's what
makes it Flawless it's the fluidity of
being able to lean on each other and the
relationships are so good and we start
to understand each other that we know
when I can stand and we also know each
other's strengths and weaknesses so we
know who to plug in because somebody's
better at this this has happened to me
where where even just as a leader my
personality I'm not getting through to
somebody on my team they're just not
listening to me but it's my personality
and so instead of me just doing the same
thing over and over again I'll ask
somebody else to fill in because their
personality might work a lot better and
it works a lot of the times um so I
think it's that ability to understand
that this is a team this is a team this
is a team at all times that is a team
that keeps the inspiration and the
desire to come to work really high I
imagine a World in which the vast
majority of people wake up inspired feel
safe wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do it is
an ideal I know that we will never get
there but we will die trying that's the
point and so I have met um many units
within the military and many units that
have failed where they are more advanced
towards that Vision than others the same
in in in the corporate world there are
some companies that are way way more
advanced in that Vision than others and
I think what's most important is the
constant striving um we we we talked
before about understanding the infinite
game by understanding the the the idea
of constant Improvement and the ones
that are making the greatest headways
it's not that they get everything right
and make every right decision they
absolutely do not it's how they deal
with uh when they make bad decisions or
how they deal with it when they get
pushed back on their heels um and the
idea of constantly improving and and
accepting that this is a moment in time
now let's move forwards um th those are
the ones that I admire